la chaîne américaine cnn at elle
participé activement à la défaite de
donald trump
c'est en tout cas ce qu un directeur
technique du média a concédé en caméra
cachée charlie chester un cadre de la
chaîne a été la victime de plusieurs
faux rendez vous amoureux filmés à son
insu
chester confie à son interlocutrice que
cnn aurait tout fait pour évincer donald
re je vais le dire et je le pense à 100
% sont cnn
je ne sais pas si trump pourrait été
viré à un moment donné la main de trump
tremblay ou quelque chose comme ça nous
avons fait appel à plusieurs médecins
pour raconter une histoire selon
laquelle et c'était de la spéculation
il avait un soucis neurologiques c'était
de la propagande une propagande anti
trump savamment orchestrée à en croire
charles i chester et qui aurait donc
profité un certain joe boyd montrions
toujours des photos de bail donne
faisant du jogging et en bonne santé
vous voyez avec ses lunettes d'aviateur
nous le montrions comme une jeune
personne âgée je pense que c'est grâce à
nous qu'il a été élu
des déclarations assez lourde de sens et
pourtant charlie chester nom n'est pas
sa dernière confession
selon lui la prochaine campagne d'
influence de la part de cnn serait déjà
déterminé
notre objectif était de mettre trump à
la porte sans le dire notre prochain
objectif concernera la sensibilisation
aux changements climatiques
ces révélations concernant le vote de
novembre risque de faire parler ces
prochains jours
et d'appuyer la thèse d'une frange des
républicains et du clan trump selon
lesquelles l'élection lors a été volé
quant à cnn elle n'avait pas forcément
besoin d'une telle publicité
après les images de chars ukrainien
illustrant une invasion russe supposée